Você já parou para pensar que a comida
de hospital pode estar atrapalhando a
recuperação dos pacientes ao invés de
ajudar? Veja bem, acabou de sair um
estudo bombástico da Lancet mostrando
que hospitais alemães estão servindo uma
dieta péssima pros pacientes. Muita
farinha refinada, açúcar, salda e quase
nada de vegetais, frutas e grãos
integrais. Agora me diz, se isso tá
acontecendo na Alemanha, imagina aqui no
Brasil. Nossos hospitais servem pãozinho
francês com margarina, suco de caixinha
cheio de açúcar, bolacha creme craque no
café da manhã. Isso é um absurdo médico.
O corpo precisa de nutrientes de verdade
para se recuperar. Proteí de qualidade
para reconstruir tecidos, vitaminas e
minerais para fortalecer o sistema
imune, fibras para regular o intestino,
paciente com doença crônica, diabetes,
problema cardíaco, comendo pão branco e
suco industrializado, tá literalmente
jogando gasolina na inflamação. A gente
tá sabotando a recuperação com comida
ultra processada, justo quando o corpo
mais precisa de nutrição de verdade. Da
próxima vez que você, alguém da família,
for internado, questione o cardápio,
exija comida de verdade,